what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar and today i will be
deep diving into the controversial love
triangle between ochako deku and toga
clearly this is the most important topic
in the current arc of the manga and it
deserves a detailed and deeply
philosophical analysis seriously though
deku just rejected toga's love and she
did not take it well toga went full
yandere and deku is desperately trying
to get away from her in order to join
the battle against perfect shigaraki so
let's get into it you guys know the
drill if you enjoy our boku no hero
videos and you want to see more in the
future just leave a quick like and
comment it only takes a second but it
really helps with that youtube algorithm
and please remember that subscribing and
hitting that bell is a completely free
but very important way of directly
supporting the channel finally this
video will contain boku no hero manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned now the previous
chapter of the mha manga was a lot of
fun we had toga confessing her love to
deku in the middle of a war and both
deku and ochoko were completely caught
off guard the text on the final page
promised that the emotions are going to
escalate even further in the following
chapter and i have to say that the manga
delivered on that promise of course
horikoshi is fully aware of how crazy it
is to interrupt a massive new war arc in
order to focus on a love triangle
featuring ayandere and i mean even the
chapter's narrator alludes to this in
the beginning of the latest chapter the
narrator talks about how deku is the
wielder of one for all the greatest
asset in battle the vessel of the quirk
that all for one wants the most and yet
in this moment our legendary hero deku
is just kind of dazed and confused and
it seems that despite his amazing power
deku still lacks confidence when it
comes to the ladies and he kind of sees
himself as a loser in that regard and i
mean that kind of does make sense he's
still just a high school kid and a
teenager with literally zero dating
experience he actually had no idea that
toga liked him like that and he asks her
what is she even talking about toga
tells deku that she had loved him ever
since she first met him he apparently
reminds togo of her first love and when
she saw him she just thought that he was
so cool i mean none of this sounds too
crazy yeah like being in love with
someone who looks exactly like your ex
is kind of weird but it's not insane
don't worry though because the insanity
is coming toga then makes like the most
yandere face ever and she says to deku i
want to become you let me suck your
blood deku is like whoa whoa you know
that being boyfriend and girlfriend just
means like going to places together and
holding hands and sharing crepes right
and for my fellow french weebs like
aoyama yes i know that it's actually
crepe but it's an english-speaking
audience so you know i'll call them
crepes anyway it's interesting that the
things which deku lists are basically
the things that he has either done or
talked about doing with ochako so
clearly in his mind deco associates
dating with dating a girl like ochoko or
rather dating ochoko herself
but toga is like no honey for me being a
couple means becoming one and the same
and nothing less will fulfill my desires
she wants to consume deku's blood and
who knows what else so that she can
literally become one with him um okay i
admit that deku is not exactly a genius
when it comes to the ladies but you
gotta cut him some slack here i mean no
one would know what to do if they found
themselves in this situation where a
crazy woman is saying that she wants to
consume him and become him meanwhile
ochako is getting the shakes as she's
listening to all of this talk about toga
consuming deku's bodily fluids
toga then asks deku the same question
that she asked ochako back in jakku hey
hiro what do you want to do to me ah
come on toga stop tempting me to make
these kinds of jokes on youtube this is
a family friendly channel to his credit
deku is attempting to understand toga
and to relate to her he says that he too
always wanted to be like almight and to
imitate his hero he says that he
understands the desire to be like
someone else and how such a desire can
drive someone and make them feel
fulfilled
at the same time deku admits that he
would never want to become one with
someone he cares about in the way that
toga is talking about and that's because
he could never hurt the people that he
cares about for deku and for all normal
people consuming someone's blood or
hurting them in any way is not the way
you express your love but toga just
doesn't understand this deku's honest
words only remind her of how she was
mistreated as a child and how everyone
just told her to be normal and stop
being weird in other words to stop being
herself toga concludes that deku and
ochako are exactly like her father and
mother and that to them only heroes and
the people that they save are valued as
people the rest don't even seem to
matter to them by the rest she is
presumably referring to villains and
those who don't quite fit into society's
definition of a normal law-abiding
citizen but let's be real this is a
massive reach on toga's part deku and
ochoko would definitely love to be able
to save everyone including villains if
only the villains were willing to amend
their ways and stop committing crimes
but what heroes like ochako and deku
cannot accept is someone like toga
continuing to hurt others because she
herself thinks that the pain she causes
is just an expression of love as heroes
who are sworn to protect people they
can't allow toga to just go around doing
whatever she wants and hurting whomever
she wants just because she's their
friend or whatever but toga just doesn't
seem to understand that to her any
attempt to convince her that her
worldview is wrong and warped is a
rejection of her true self and she
doesn't take it well actually that is a
massive understatement because toga
absolutely loses it she goes completely
crazy she goes full yandere and she
brutally attacks deku and yet even as
she is attacking deku deku's danger
sense still doesn't activate this is
because toga's worldview is so warped
that in her own mind she literally
doesn't know the difference between
expressing love for someone and hurting
someone so dangerous sense cannot pick
up on her ill intentions because even as
she attacks deku her intentions are
genuinely good in her own mind they are
just completely twisted and warped deku
is having a tough time detecting toga in
such close quarters because not only is
dangerous sense not working but toga
also has her stealth ability that she is
using to her advantage toga declares
that ever since she met deku she just
couldn't stop thinking about him but now
she has decided that she will not think
about him anymore she is through with
him and with everyone else the world has
done nothing but reject her and now she
is going to reject the world deku
included ochako knows how important deku
is for defeating shigaraki and she also
loves him let's be real so she jumps in
to hell
toga looks like she's about to cut
ochako and potentially even kill her but
thankfully tsuyu shows up and dropkicks
toga away from ochako however toga did
manage to get some of mochuko's blood on
her knife while toga is down tsuyu tells
deku that this is not the time or the
place to talk about romance he has to
get out of here and get back to ua to
help with fighting shigeraki ochiko
agrees and assures deku that they can
take it from here as toga gets back to
her feet her blades levitating around
her like drones she goes ultra instinct
yandere she screams why is life so hard
even though i love you so much and
ochako tells deku to run then deku is
like himiko honey i'll be right back i
just gotta get some milk from the store
and he takes off running so fast that he
looks like he's actually running on
water i'm not sure if this is just to
create a cool effect or if he's actually
planning to run across the ocean in
order to get back to the mainland i
think i'd rather him have to actually
find some form of transportation rather
than just walking on water like jesus
but we'll see what happens my takeaway
from this chapter is what i've been
saying for a long time toga does
genuinely love certain people including
deku if she didn't then danger sense
would have gone off however toga
expresses that love in completely
twisted and violent ways and that is
simply incompatible with a properly
functioning society we of course live in
a society where we have to protect
people from unwanted violence from
others deku's idea of romance is a far
more traditional one than togas and it
is clear that deku is much more
compatible with a girl like ochako than
a girl like toga i mean is literally
anyone compatible with a girl like toga
anyone other than my editor axel
apparently to me this chapter makes it
clear that deku will choose ochoko in
his own mind he probably chose her
already and i think that might be the
trigger that ultimately motivates toga
to activate sad man's parade we have to
remember that toga is driven by emotion
not by strategy or logic toga won't use
sad man's parade because she wants to
make a strategic contribution to the
fight against the heroes or because like
all for one tells her to she will do it
when she is emotionally driven to do it
and deku and ochako ending up together
is the kind of heartbreaking moment that
could trigger her into using that
ultimate attack but just so no one can
say that i didn't give toga a fair
chance i will bring in my editor axel
beats who is a notorious toga fanboy and
an expert on toga's totally non-insane
world view maybe he can enlighten us
about toga's current state of mind and
what she might do next take it away axel
so first off we gotta talk about
something if we keep disrespecting the
queen that is toga on this channel i'm
gonna need a raise but on the topic of
this video i do think he got a lot of
things right toga has made her move and
she was turned down by both deku
and ochako and when a character's entire
world view stems from the idea of being
neglected from people who are supposed
to love her and now is centered around
people who she loves and currently
revolves around the idea of getting
revenge against people who don't accept
who she is at her core we could
definitely be seeing the sparks that set
off sad man's parade however i think we
first need to talk about the original
user of sadman's parade to really see
how things will shake out with toga ever
since twice died there has been a shift
in toga's character as he melted in her
arms she thanked him for saving her life
for showing her that she could be loved
and accepted as she is but from that
moment she begins to change
while she's always been eccentric and
impulsive toga slows down and begins to
question things to her sure twice was a
villain but he was also just a really
good person and i don't think that
anyone who's watched or read along with
my hero academia would really disagree
with the concept of twice being this
sympathetic or understandable character
yeah he did bad things but i wouldn't
personally say that he was evil but all
the same the heroes killed him
leaving toga to ask at what point do
they draw the line
if it's a hero's duty to save people
was jin not a person in their eyes
and will they kill me as well we see in
the most recent chapter her comparing
both ochako and deku to her parents
people who she believed didn't think of
her as a person thus seeing her as not
worthy of being saved we mentioned in
this video how toga asks what they would
want to do with her and yes at face
value it's hilarious haha naughty joke
but that isn't what she was asking to
toga deku and ochako are real heroes
just like stain was they believe in
justice and more importantly they want
to help everyone that they can
they aren't like the phony heroes who
killed twice so when she's asking
what would they like to do with her
she's actually asking hey
i'm different i don't belong but i'm
still a person right so how would you
help me
can you even help me and if you can't
will you just kill me like you did twice
toga's at a crossroads she has been
desperately looking at deku and ochako
to show that they are different than the
rest of the heroes and if they turn her
away like her parents did
then sad man's parade is likely imminent
however if they do offer to help then
sad man's parade could be a powerful
tool in being used against the villains
instead sure toga has this insatiable
desire to want to consume people's blood
but she isn't really acting on it for
the most part she herself says she's
holding it back and that she wants to be
friends with ochako and talk about love
and about deku
but why is she holding it back if she's
supposed to be this evil villain
why would she want to make friends if
she just wants to destroy everything
like shigaraki it's because she doesn't
want that she showed up to join the
league of villains because she wanted to
be like stain and to her
stain wasn't a villain
he was a hero trying to make things
better to toga killing a bad hero like
stain was doing is no worse than parents
abandoning their daughter for being
different it's no different from heroes
ignoring people who don't fit in and it
certainly wasn't any different than
choosing to kill twice because he had
the potential to hurt other people even
though he himself was a good person
they're all just choices that people had
to make hoping to make the world a
better place and if they're ruthless and
if they're cold
then so is the world toga holds herself
back because even though she wants blood
she doesn't actually want to ruin lives
part of her wants to be a hero but if
the world is cancerous and broken if
people keep turning away from people
like her who need help
then maybe there's just nothing worth
saving as animax says almost every time
she's in a chapter
yes she is kinda nuts she doesn't fit
into modern society but that doesn't
mean she should be treated as less than
human if the world saw you as nothing
you might want to fight back as well and
i personally can't blame her for doing
so but that's just kind of my views on
toga where she's at mentally right now
and what the possibility of sad man's
parade going forward really are i think
that depending on her interactions with
ochako in the next few chapters things
could definitely fall on either side of
the coin but here's hoping for the best
let me know what you guys think in the
comments down below and as always if you
enjoyed this video remember to leave a
like and subscribe to the channel for
more but until next time remember to
stay excellent